and we're back so why didn't anyone tell
me I was about to get an existential
flashback that lasted an entire volume
of the story huh why didn't anyone warn
me about how emotionally vulnerable this
would make me I thought we had a rapport
I trusted you in the material I covered
for the first video arakawa proved to me
that she knew how to set up interesting
themes and an engaging world in the
second video's material she showed me
she wasn't all talk and could deliver
some of the absolute best fight scenes
I've ever seen and now this week she's
pulling out all the stops and I know in
the first video I said oh this is gonna
be a three video series well guess what
nerds times change sometimes plans don't
go the way you thought they would
sometimes you naively begin with a
vision of how you see things going and
maybe you had to compromise your vision
in the name of something you didn't
believe in and in the process struggle
to justify the Newfound blood in your
hands but resolutely you trudge forward
in the name of your dream despite how
impossible it might say oh God I'd ride
Mustang you have my heart and my ax but
enough Preamble it's time to get into
the emotional thick of it with the
beginning of this video in a surprising
turn of events as we dive into the past
of Full Metal Alchemists
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thing I would like to know actually is
whether or not at this point in the
story did anime only fans know that
hornheim was actually some super power
dude and could tank like 10 bullets to
the chest that they were nothing I mean
I think from the stuff I covered last
week that has to be the wildest sign how
could the anime skip that Scene It seems
really important like surely they must
have replaced it with something
afterwards to Clue the audience in right
so yeah please if anyone has any answers
to this question let me know in the
comments down below with that aside we
opened this week with a tense scene one
where King Brad confronts Mustang Al and
Ed over being exposed as a big dumb
tattoo eye having bad guy but what
struck me as the most creepy aspect was
how calm the atmosphere was Edward was
allowed to mouth off and defuse any and
all attention with humor it feels as
though there's a sense that Ed is in
control at times or at the very least
isn't as concerned as they should be
that is until Bradley reveals the ace up
his sleeve one that again Harkens back
to a bunch of volumes prior when he had
a private conversation with winry he's
been so far ahead of the game it's nuts
to think about and now to keep Ed and Co
in line Winery safety is threatened if
they don't cooperate so not great
that actually surprised me massively and
thankfully nothing happens to the little
girl however what it did bring to the
focus is that there are some things that
these guys will inevitably be unable to
account for and that's the cunning of
the hero's side and one character
embodies this more than any other in my
book particularly in this section and he
was my favorite from last week's
material and man does he pull wood out
of the hot tears this week to get a
message out despite not actually being
in control
this is such a cool idea and God I love
link like this was such a smooth move
and it creates a wonderful tension
around the new greed and how he might be
compromised by Ling moving forward this
I am certain will lead to some amazing
swerves at the final hour later on it's
got surprise bait written all over it
but I think from this early portion of
this week's material my main point of
focus has to be on a throwaway line by
some of the townsfolk Ed helps out later
on they mentioned that the other
Alchemist sent earlier could transmute
anything to help them fix the town it
claimed that correlated with the exact
moment Ed at his powers taken away by
pipe man I actually don't know what his
name is what is his name what do people
call him father okay yeah taken away by
father all right that sounds kind of
kinky but whatever oh kinky and so that
made me wonder is this dude a literal
God is Father a god there was some
Exposition earlier alluding to the
position mission for Alchemy being
similar to that of prayer and this
falder figure can turn off the
transmutation powers of everyone not
just those he chooses why does he look
like hoenheim this all makes no sense to
me I'm really left scratching my head
with this one guys I mean I have no idea
what's going on however this isn't the
part I alluded to in my intro instead
it's the material contained within
volume 15. it's deeply troubling deals
with some very serious subject matter
it's very much Loosely inspired by real
life events that arakawa researched and
interviewed former vets for this is the
origin of the story itself and the
foundation's Fullmetal Alchemist as a
story are built upon told to the
perspectives of both scar DeMarco as
well as Hawkeye to Edward upon request
the curtain is finally pulled on the
troubling past as were hurled years and
years into the ishviland Civil War
I'm very much a fan of getting a chance
to see the past Civil War that acts as a
backdrop to all the story that's taken
place it's great to see scenes with
winry's parents and getting to see where
she got her Healing Hands from being a
mechanic in this day and age may as well
be a doctor to her friends and clients
at this point now I want to make clear
that I do love this section and I mean
love this section with a capital L and I
will explain why in just a moment but I
do have one issue with it and while it
is a nitpick I will say this isn't the
first time arakawa has taken this
approach and had the same narrative
issue like I said moments ago this is a
story told from the points of view of
Hawkeye predominantly and that's the
problem the fact that this is presented
through flashbacks from Individual
perspectives there are certain scenes
where I was left wondering how Hawkeye
or even Marco were aware of the details
concerning certain important and pivotal
conversations they otherwise had no
information on we see scenes where the
high commands strategize and discuss
their evil schemes it should be said
that I'm perfectly happy with the
information revealed it's extremely
interesting and engaging my issue alone
is with the clunky choice to present it
in the flashback of a particular
character that would have had no idea
about these secrets and private
conversations how did you know about the
part you weren't there for the World War
II analog with enough comparisons are
very clear from the brutal mistreatment
of a race of people all the way to the
medical experimentation on live Human
subjects even the flame Alchemist of the
past in a way feels like the creator of
the atomic bomb he created something
spectacularly powerful but in the
process assured the deaths of billions
with its very creation there's a very
interesting commentary here concerning
the place of generational responsibility
and the shouldering of atrocities in the
name of potential future peace it's a
haunting concept and when I was thrilled
to see explored in this volume our good
friend Ron like any bright-eyed youth
unfamiliar with the horrors of humanity
trusts in his abilities to leverage this
power for good he didn't want to bring
destruction but Unity to this world from
the perspective of Scar I think this
story succeeds in painting a very Grim
image of war and presents the perfect
setup for scarra's inevitable Revenge
story unlike Ed scar is the concerned
and scared younger of two brothers with
his older brother due to his love for
his family electing to replace skara's
severed arm that he lost in combat with
his own thematically this is quite
powerful and Visually communicates that
very theme effectively through saving
scarra's life his older brother
sacrificed himself Awakening on the
table of winry's parents following those
horrific events scar is left with an arm
that has only the power to deconstruct
or destroy it's a nice visual metaphor
for the Revenge loss a grief-stricken
younger brother might feel when his
family and people have been wrongfully
ripped away from him Young Ron despite
getting the powers he was so convinced
he could change the world with for the
better sees himself burdened instead
with an immeasurable responsibility and
a death toll he wasn't prepared to
shoulder everything in this section
shows the naivety of the youth and the
death the older Generations bring with
them for these people to endure the
utter indifference of it all that they
feel with the best quote from this
section being from Ron Mustang himself
he says you say I'm an idealist but
unless someone chases after pipe dreams
nothing will change
oh uh actually you know what I made a
mistake you see I said scar shared his
story but in actuality it wasn't him but
it was Dr Marco informing scare of what
happened back during that time of the
Civil War the reason I was so confused
by this was because we see Scar's entire
backstory in the manga for which Dr
Marco would have absolutely no clue
about yet somehow we see it firstly I do
want to say however that as a story in
flashback these sequences work
remarkably well and are fantastically
engaging this is one of my favorite
sections of the entire story but the
framework of this flashback the logic of
who's telling this story and from what
perspective just makes absolutely no
sense at all interestingly the
Brotherhood anime actually fixes that
flashback issue with scar instead
showing us this portion of Scar's
backstory when he's faced with the gun
from Winery a while back so I guess it's
important to remember that 100
authenticity to the manga can be a bad
thing like
foreign
[Music]
for the first time alongside one of my
friends and together we're trying to
predict who Pride will eventually be
revealed as at one point my friends seem
to be convinced that it was this
Kimberly dude he did seem like an
obvious candidate he killed more people
with his smile in his face than what
many might conceive as normal but I do
however think it can't be him from a
narrative and framing standpoint it
makes little sense to me at least for
him to be Pride though I will say not
impossible of course something this
story is trying to do is taunt and tease
us into guessing pride is he's being
consistently out of frame during any and
all interactions he participates in and
so I'm convinced it's going to be
someone we least expect and that means
in my mind someone on the side of good
the more convinced we are in their
innocence the better and more surprised
will ultimately be so I thought to
myself who are the candidates and three
names came to mind well okay technically
four but I'm less sure of the last one
Dr Knox is my first guess admittedly I
don't actually think this is very likely
he goes way back with everyone has the
trust of Mustang and has ties to the
military in some shape and form he'd be
a useful pawn and source of information
but uh yeah I'm not convinced it's him
he seems extremely genuine but if not
him how about Dr Marco as you can see I
don't much trust the doctors this is the
person I am least sure of and honestly
is more a shot in the dark than anything
else seeing his Barker's identity has
already been compromised before and in
order for it to be him arakawa would
have needed to have been playing the
long con even when main story characters
weren't looking and to be honest that's
is kind of cheap and I honestly don't
think it's what she would do next up
Hawkeye Hawkeye is getting a lot of
screen time right now lots of time in
front of our eyes and we've been bonded
to her specifically honestly I still
think this one is a long shot I give it
like a 20 success rate but my final pick
I am 40 sure it could be her at Maria
Ross how perfect would it be for her to
be someone that's being close to the
action since day one how fortunate is it
that she's been effectively written off
the story I think there's a decent
chance it could be her and that her
framing was all a ploy to get the
traitors in the military to reveal
themselves but we shall see how right or
more likely how extremely wrong I am
also another long shot I found him he
just got transferred up north that
becomes important later and uh yeah
maybe
baby hayate the dog god the dog is like
I feel like that's a genius pick if it's
the dog man that would be an amazing
shot in the dark but yeah anyway back to
the story Full Metal Alchemist
everything else what
orchestrates is that the Philosopher's
Stone allows those who wield it to in
some way bypass Equivalent Exchange
could this be the reason why father was
able to do the same and manifest what he
needed for Al perhaps he's not a God but
in fact a delusional old man holding a
gross bloody Stone and honestly as I
look at him growing gluttony on his
chest like a mother with an infant at
her bosom I can't help but feel like I
don't have even enough information to
know for certain or make an educated
guess for that matter
foreign
aside from that there are some great
contrast made between the prior
generation and the current older ones
with those like Hawkeye Armstrong and
Mustang expressing a clear willingness
to absorb the depressing situation
before them walk through a river of
blood and corpses all in the name of
peace for the future generations to come
there's a very strong anti-war message
in this volume that manages to say what
it wants without feeling pretentious or
like it's oversimplifying the greater
issue at the beginning of Volume 15
arakawa wrote in researching this volume
I interviewed veterans who had been at
the front during World War II I read
countless books examined film footage
and listened to many detailed and
intense stories first hand but the one
comment that affected me the most came
from a former soldier who lowered his
gaze to the tabletop and said I never
watch horror movies war is an extremely
complicated situation and topic to
tackle and as a writer I think it's
tantalizing to want to preach and tell
your own story and perspective but
instead arakawa from the life
experiences of those she's interviewed
built a world that reflected that and
populated it with characters that she
could then speak for react how they
would react perform how they would
perform and feel how they would choose
to cope but in the pits of Despair she
offers us a shunning light at the end as
the new generations offer hope for the
future and whether it be naive and
idealistic wishes or Stern conviction
it's comforting to see that even those
ill-equipped idealistic trainee soldiers
managed to find the resolve necessary to
survive and not get lost in the past
acts that they were once instructed to
commit it's a similar situation in
philosophy that Edward find himself in
and employs regularly to this day move
forward with a great dream for the
future don't focus on your failings or
all you will contribute is failure
foreign
[Music]
while Volume 15 was crammed full of
Juicy material volume 16 comparatively
takes its time and is a volume that
consists of largely set up establishing
three clear parties that are all going
to converge at an hour looking for the
little girl with the weird panda bear
thing so they can learn that
purification Alchemy to better deal with
that father guy down the road group
number two is scared now accompanied by
the man he sprung from captivity Dr
Marco along with that little girl that
they're after
they are now heading north for where
scar stashed his older brother's
research and finally Kimberly the most
sadistic killer in this story
established perfectly during the last
volume he is released from prison in an
effort to bolster the sight of evil sent
on a mission North to take out scar
truth be told this very much feels like
a very distinct and different section of
the story to anything else revealed to
us thus far not just how it's structured
in being this cat and mouse Trifecta of
possibilities Heroes antagonists and
anti-heroes but just as crucially in how
the entire section is catered to by its
environment however this doesn't mean
that we are entirely leaving behind
Central City far from it Mustang will of
course continue his under the radar
quest for resources leads and allies
while all of this is going on but what I
will say is that so much of this story
has seen these characters color the
pages of rolling fields or confined City
Landscapes like this and naturally this
made a lot of sense and I'm not
complaining about it in the slightest
but what I am thrilled about concerning
this local ship is how different its
environment allows the story to feel
don't stop
[Music]
foreign
Fortress is designed characterized and
led in the manga is spectacularly
distinct to anywhere else we've seen up
until now everything from the
environment to the challenges that
creates and the temperament of the
soldiers and leaders in this Barracks
all complement each other creating
wonderful new opportunities for tension
Major General Armstrong is one such
character that embodies this setting
cold calculated and Stern she and her
loyal soldiers survive here because of
their trust and respect for one another
which ends up proving to be their most
valuable quality when Kimberly is
released from prison and makes his way
North in pursuit of Scar the scene where
these two eventually meet on the train
is framed very dramatically in the manga
and honestly I thought this was going to
be some very action-packed fight and
while there is action in it once again
arikawa undercuts the moment with an
opportune dose of reality bringing to
light how out of shape Kimberly must
have been in comparison to scar who's
been fighting all of these years and the
results speak for themselves Kimberly
being brought to hospital with a big
wound But ultimately comes into contact
with HQ and eventually into the Fortress
where Edward and Al arrive thanks to the
use of his Philosopher's Stone but not
before Edward and Al and the Fortress
itself is infiltrated suddenly by an
unknown enemy
now I'm at not gonna lie when this dude
erupted from the floor beneath uh two
things ran through my head one who the
hell is that and why are they tunneling
the answer to those questions will be
answered right now
I quickly realized that I had in fact
for a split second before being
introduced to sloth long ago as an enemy
he offers a thrilling new challenge ripe
with possibilities with him being a de
facto armored tank with quite literally
no brain power at all direct attacks
won't work Fire won't work and so the
forces of Briggs along with Armstrong
work together to push the Beast outside
into the freezing Tundra it's a moment
of strategic genius in my opinion and
once again leverages what makes this
area that much more interesting and
unique in the first place and through
exploring the seamlessly endless tunnel
this creature created Armstrong and all
her gorgeous beautiful strategic wisdom
uses this as an opportunity to entice
the up until now tight-lipped Elric
Brothers into spilling the beans on what
exactly they haven't been telling her
about high command and these tunnels but
in summation they are all linked to
other key points of the surrounding area
where prior battles or Civil Wars had
been raged making for a enormous
transmutation circle it's here all the
pieces fall into place and were once
again told what Hughes died for uncovery
from there they formulate a measured and
subtle plan of attack
[Music]
God I love this character she is
incredibly resourceful and measured with
every move she takes and even later in
moments where Ed and Al overextend
themselves or have to think on the fly
her situation is always the most stable
thanks to her initial approach God I am
so happy she's on her side another
something completely different
I think it's fair to say at this point
that with every consecutive scene
hohenheim participates in I have less of
an understanding of what exactly is
going on here he's like anti-exposition
he's like the ants from my brain I don't
know I'm bad with words and moreover my
theory about hohenheim is entirely dead
in the water now he does seem to be
immortal and as a result thinks of
himself as a monster so much so that he
doesn't want to touch his children for
fear that it might infect them with some
sort of curse that he has perhaps then
he leaves for research Trisha dying from
a sickness seems oddly convenient now at
this point but who knows for sure I mean
things regarding this particular
storyline have been so crazy I'm
honestly willing and waiting for him to
take off a mask and be all like it was
me Austin it was me all along and you
know what if that did happen it wouldn't
be the weirdest thing hornheim has done
and just to throw more fuel in the fire
that was my brain at this point
this happens
[Music]
there's a wonderful sense of camaraderie
in the Briggs Fortress and when the
soldiers go down into the tunnel where
the other soldiers disappear to save
them the coming scenes and setting is
horrific this entire section has a real
sense of fear and horror I'm a massive
fan of the cold as a horror setting the
restrictions it puts on the situation
and its characters is perfect for this
sort of tale everyone is trapped inside
this Fortress monsters beneath them
deathly cold outside and enemies all
around it's such a wonderfully tense and
brilliantly executed context for the
main characters to be contained within
particularly now then Winery is here and
then of course the story proves me wrong
yet again
[Music]
foreign
now I want to make one thing perfectly
clear so I'm not a complete and total
failure in your eyes while I didn't
predict this kid was Pride even one
chapter before he was revealed to be the
OG homunculus I did predict it was him
at the last possible moment where I can
say I somewhat predicted it and it's all
because of the words his mother chose to
describe him at the beginning of this
scene when she said he was quote her
pride and joy I was like
is the little bastard there he is but
then immediately after I'm like damn it
they revealed it right away all my
predictions were wrong again I really
thought I was on to something with the
dog that would have been hilarious and
honestly kind of genius and I'm proud
that I guessed that but the kid being
Pride here works too I guess he's the
first humongous and he's surrounded by
the darkness that killed those soldiers
in the tunnel so I guess now we know how
they died but interestingly on the topic
of Pride's Revelation Apparently one
year before Pride's identity was ever
revealed someone actually guessed who it
was it's a very interesting read I
highly recommend it
[Music]
the conversation or should I say
confrontation between Kimberly and
Edward is fantastic it's a perfect
example of rising tension and Stakes as
Kimberly reveals what he wants Edward to
do Ed refuses naturally and asks why he
does what he's doing if he's not a
humunculus and through that disclosure
we learn just how twisted and cruel
Kimberly actually is like a goebbles
from Hitler's ranks someone that can get
things done and isn't afraid or should I
say a morally bankrupt and insane enough
to get his hands dirty and that's when
everything Ed has ever wanted is dangled
right in front of him the answer to his
quest for his brother's body his arm his
leg the answer to everything they've
been seeking together the Philosopher's
Stone is offered to him for his
cooperation and now he has to decide
what is more important what he wants or
his morals this is a textbook example of
what a villain can offer for a hero in a
story it exposes the villain's true
nature and taunts the hero away from
what makes them just I love moments like
this because it really establishes the
difference between the two characters
involved and exposes who they really are
For Better or For Worse and later once
Ed Allen Winery fake agreed to help
Kimberly search for scar another
opportunity present itself for winry to
reveal who she really is
[Music]
upon finding and cornering scar
following a chimera attack in a similar
fashion how Ed and Al were handed
everything they wanted on a silver
platter with Kimberly so too is winry in
this situation restrained in front of
her she confronts him and instead of
succumbing to her darker feelings
concerning him she uses her Healing
Hands not to hurt him but instead
bandage up his wounds and right after
this is yet more fuel for a wacky theory
of mind
if negative feelings build up the flow
of the world will become negative on the
other hand it's possible to accumulate
positive feelings and make the world
flow in a positive direction once again
this is a very interesting choice of
words recalled back to by Scar that his
older brother said to him a quote that
in my mind maps onto the sort of alchemy
or purification art May and her culture
has become proficient using this idea
that her power comes from the flow of
energy in the earth it makes me wonder
if this story is framing the sort of
alchemy Edward Mustang and Allah use as
that of negativity it's a tool of War
used by the dogs of the military used to
harness power for violent ends whereas
the purification Arts are derived
specifically from medicine used to help
and to heal people and so I wonder if
this negativity that's being sown
through constant War hatred racism and
Revenge by the forces of evil I wonder
if it bolsters their power while the
decisions Edward and Winery made in this
volume like not accepting to use
something so morally reprehensible like
the Philosopher's Stone or simply
enduring and breaking the cycle of
hatred in Winery circumstance is the
greater theme of this story to not take
the easy way out for everyone's own
selfish desires but to instead go that
extra mile because it's the right thing
to do so much of what general Raven
depends on when trying to convince
Armstrong is her ego he tries to prey on
her fear of Aging or material or selfish
desires and expressly points out that
there will of course need to be
sacrifices sacrifices he is okay with
because he specifically is one of the
Chosen Few that will reap the rewards
and not any of the negatives but yeah
that's just my theory Here and Now
[Music]
all right so this looks bad and it is
but not for the reasons one might
initially think and I love that about
this story however this also marks the
last time Ed will see his brother until
the Day of Reckoning and truth be told
while things are still falling into
place even this far out I must say I am
extremely excited for what will be the
final video in this series next week but
before we get to the Day of Reckoning
okay before I move on to that material
we first need to set this chessboard up
and there's some amazing stuff I think
my favorite part about this remaining
section is the level of covert Ops
assumptions and risks the hero side
needs to rely on to advance in any small
way they can arikawa has done a
fantastic job of spreading all the key
characters all over the map quite
literally and as a result we have so
many unlikely scenarios and team-ups for
instance I get the feeling at this point
that our account wants to separate
Edward and Al before they inevitably
reunite at the end of the story and
embrace our lovey-dovey but in order to
do that she needs a just cause and man
the justification she comes up with is
again simple but utterly genius we all
know scar is taking Winery in this
instance because it takes her quite
literally out of a hostage situation and
Ed is hoping that Kimberly will buy this
but unfortunately he doesn't and in fact
he's already sent Central goons all over
Fort Briggs where her scar and the rest
of Team hero are heading and so because
they need to be warned and no one can go
outside in this blizzard Hal is sent
because he can't feel the cold he's the
only one that can do it and that's
brilliant and it creates the necessary
distance between the two main characters
it's a golden decision and on top of
that this happens
and I know what you're thinking you're
right I don't know what that means
you're catching on but thankfully
arakawa is a gracious God and bestowed
upon me the greatest gift this story can
bestow understanding because we finally
get context for ho and I'm or should I
say slave number 23. I think if you left
me with this story up until now for a
dozen years I wouldn't have ever guessed
that he was a living Philosopher's Stone
I would never have put those pieces
together and I would never have put him
and the lost city of Xerxes together at
all let alone that he was once upon a
time with all the sins that said it does
all make sense now but perhaps my
favorite aspect of this flashback and
Creator conflict comes from something
that was said about humankind in general
man in this section is described as
having all of the seven deadly sins
inside of them and that those sins all
play a role in carving out the terrible
situations the world is facing today and
this very much feels like a real live
commentary arakawa is making on modern
society in general
alright so this fight scene it's
spectacular and it's great in my mind
for one specific reason this will sound
really random as hell but trust me I'll
bring it back again to Fullmetal
Alchemist
I love all aspects of this story that
rely on the mechanics that granted
novelty so what do I mean by that well
in 2016 a film called Sing produced by
illumination entertainment reminded me
of how crucial this quality Full Metal
Alchemist has this is a film saying that
quite literally did not need to design
animals as the main characters in order
for the film to work and in my mind
that's a problem in fact them being
animals are not utilizing that not only
makes their appearance entirely
pointless but leaves so much on the
table for exploration that it's
frustrating on the flip side if you look
at a film like zootopia which came out
that same year the characters being
animals is quite literally integral to
the plot the story itself wouldn't make
sense without that aspect and you might
think that sounds like a weakness but
it's really not it's a strength using
elements of your story that make a
unique weaving it into the plot not only
gives your story a sense of identity but
also makes it that much more enjoyable
and unique there are a million stories
like that which sing demonstrates but
there are no stories like zootopia or in
this case
Full Metal Alchemist like there's this
battle that erupts once Kimberly outs
himself as totally in the know regarding
their Ambush and six two chimeras on Ed
during this battle Ed uses the very
alchemy that makes this story unique to
defeat the chimeras by removing the
ammonia from the sticks of dynamite he
found around him that is such a fun and
inventive idea but it's also an approach
to combat literally no other story can
do without straight up copying arakawa's
power system here it's a great idea this
is exactly what I look for in a great
fight injecting elements that make the
story unique and interesting and on the
topic of battle something I noticed and
haven't mentioned yet is that there are
a number of instances where it would be
convenient or expedient for Edward and
Al to just kill their enemies and move
on without a second thought they are
reminded time and again that that trait
that they possess that softness will get
them killed that it's a weakness and
this can be reflected in how they try to
bring the cameras over to their way of
thinking but I genuinely think it's this
philosophy that the older generation
calls naive that will once and for all
break the cycle of negativity revenge
and violence that this land has endured
for hundreds of years if we care for
everyone's well-being and even our
greatest enemies then there's truly hope
for peace and that is something more
infinitely more than what prior
Generations have offered however that
doesn't mean that along the way there
won't be some truly devastating speed
bumps
foreign
[Music]
this freaked me the hell out as Ed
discovers how massively injured he is
I'm reminded that this is the first
major time his physical human body has
sustained any significant damage and at
that very moment Al falls to the ground
I guess their theory about Edward and Al
being tied together is true in some way
in addition to that hohenheim delivers a
message to Pride for Father which is
pretty cool Kimberly decides to bring
the drachma Army to the door of Fort
Briggs or a Chad and envy is tipped off
to the whereabouts of Winery and Co
which would be all fine but for some
reason when I finished reading that last
bit closing volume 19 and opening volume
20 to start the next chapter suddenly a
mini time skip happens the battle at
Fort Briggs is over Edward is fully
healed and envy is already after
catching up with scar Winery and the
rest I found that a little jarring when
I was reading I won't lie particularly
because we already felt as though we
were building up to a proper time skip
but yeah I don't know did the anime do
anything different did you guys feel
this way around this section let me know
in the comments
foreign
this is one of the coolest fight scenes
man like again using everything that
makes the story unique and it even
managed to give Dr Marco everyone's
favorite man in his knees crying a
chance to redeem himself in some
capacity and what a finish like holy
hell
I mean I love that they confuse Envy
with this strange Zing Alchemy but when
Marco revealed that he has a
transmutation circle etched onto his
palm and just blows the ever-loving poop
out of Envy leaving them as a shriveled
a prune of a homunculus I felt all sorts
of catharsis or did I so as a quick
break from the weird and terrible stuff
in this video there was one scene that
actually got me to tear up a little bit
or should I say online it's a blink and
you miss it moment but it occurs between
Rose and winry when they first talk and
it's great
good
line that Harkens back for me to the
very first moment I really fell in love
with this story back when Ed told Rose
to pick herself off and said that she
should be grateful that she has two
strong legs that can lift her up and
take her to where she needs to be I
didn't realize then how much a sentence
like that would mean in the broader
context of this story and in many ways
it reminded me quite a lot of a similar
moment that occurs in berserk towards
the end of its very first Arc and it
just goes to show once again that The
Healing Hands the kindness that so many
might color in the older generation as
weakness can not only change the quality
for one person's life but as Rose says
can indirectly save the lives of
hundreds maybe even thousands that's a
brilliant moment and one that arakawa
really brought to life in just one short
sentence it's it's beautiful and oh yeah
here
creepy lifeless doll
yeah that's not good but you know what
is good greed but okay not literally
okay the person the person and I'm so
happy because like I was always a fan of
greed the character not the thing yeah
the character even on day one I was a
fan of him I was all in on this
character loved his Vibe but then he
died big sad right but now he's back
with his original memories and
full-blown anti-hero there's an
absolutely epic conversation or
confrontation between greed and Edward
that takes place right at the end of
volume 20 and in it has a really nice
contrast to Greed and Edward's last
encounter where Ed absolutely
disregarded any and all consideration of
working with him right now Ed puts his
pride to the side and agrees to be his
henchman lowering himself and the quotes
man the quotes are fantastic greed says
are you sure you won't regret it meaning
this decision to which Ed responds don't
insult me my whole life's been a lesson
on regret man I just love this story I
love these characters and right now all
of them are spread out across the world
the map of this world that arakawa has
built for us readying themselves to come
together for that fabled day of
reckoning everyone is either in hiding
preparation undercover or straight up
chilling with the bad guys ready to make
their move but man is this buildup
Sublime and I honestly cannot wait to
finish off this incredible series next
week I am on my hands and knees hoping
and praying that arikawa lands this
ending and delivers what should be a
near perfect conclusion to a story but
that'll do it for this week I'm toy not
mark thank you all so much for watching
and I'll see you all next week
[Music]
foreign